Існують правила поводження зі зброєю. Зі зброєю завжди треба поводитися, як з зарядженою.
Ніколи не можна класти палець на спуск, якщо ви не готові стріляти.
Завжди треба переконатися, що перед мішенню і що за нею.
Киянин Євген Ковтун - програміст. Через 2 місяці після початку війни
Євген вирішив придбати помпову рушницю. Хлопець розуміє, що у випадку
повторного нападу на його місто, така зброя не стане у нагоді.
Тому розглядає її як засіб самозахисту, а також як можливість потренуватися.
Захиститись від агресора загалом допоможе наявність зброї, в тому плані,
коли нам роздавали автомати Калашникова з камазів, багато людей навіть
не знали правил поводження зі зброєю. Клали палець на спусковий гачок,
не знали, як це заряджати. Тобто якесь як базове тренування - воно може допомогти.
З 1 березня цього року наказом МВС спростили процедуру видачі громадянам України
дозволу на придбання та носіння мисливської зброї на час воєнного стану.
Підвищений попит у магазинах помітив і Євген, який цікавився придбанням рушниця.
Раніше коли я заходив у магазин, я міг бути один, і мені продавець міг розповідати про все.
Зараз зброю розкупають тільки так. Купа людей, в магазинах зброї черги
- чого я раніше ніколи не бачив.
Згідно з опитуванням соціологічної групи "Рейтинг", вперше за історію досліджень
кількість прихильників права на володіння українцями вогнепальної зброї
та боєприпасами переважає над противниками цієї ідеї.
У травні 2022 року право на зброю підтримували 58% опитуваних,
тоді як у 2018-2021 тільки приблизно 25% респондентів голосували "за" цю ідею.
Мисливська нарізна або гладкоствольна зброя і так була легалізована для звичайних українців.
Однак частина громадянського суспільства наголошувала щодо важливості
дозволу користування короткоствольною зброєю.
Оті ці всі права насправді нічого не важать, коли немає права на самозахист.
Коли щось кажете - то ви не можете себе захистити.
Ось це право - це право на самозахист. Самозахист має бути підкріплений.
Ми можемо захищати себе словом, кулаками або якимись охоронцями.
Найпростіше для всіх - це захищати себе пістолетом.
Тому що пістолетом може користуватися кожен.
І це об'єктивно ефективний засіб самозахисту. Не нападу, а самозахисту!
За день до повномасштабного вторгнення Росії, Верховна Рада ухвалила
в першому читанні законопроєкт про право на цивільну вогнепальну зброю,
який би встановлював порядок обігу зброї.
Цей крок був важливим, оскільки до цього цивільний обіг зброї
регулювався лише підзаконним актом МВС.
Суспільні відносини мають бути врегульовані на найвищому рівні
в системі нормативно-правових актів.
А найвищим нормативним-правовим актом є закон.
Звісно, така річ як обіг зброї - тут не посперечаєшся щодо важливості
цього виду суспільних відносин. Тому поєднуючи ці дві тези, ми приходимо до того,
що обіг зброї має бути врегульований саме законом, а не підзаконним актом,
який майже весь час був в Україні.
Однак законопроєкт піддався шквалу критики, зокрема і тому,
що не передбачав придбання та носіння пістолетів для самозахисту.
Володіти короткоствольною зброєю знову дозволялося би тільки окремим групам осіб.
На думку Єлісея Холодовського, дозвіл на володіння пістолетами
нічого не змінить у безпековій ситуації країни.
Вибачте, у нас у Києві порядком 400 000 людей, десь 10% володіють зброєю.
Це в Києві. Тобто 1 з 10 володіє зброєю. Рушницею чи карабіном.
Вже 30 років, я абсолютно не бачу ризиків, чому люди будуть володіти ще якоюсь зброєю.
Холодсковський вважає, що правки до цього пункту законопроєкту
можуть внести у другому читанні. Ще одним із показників, що ситуація може
змінитися на користь короткоствольної зброї, було опитування в додатку Дія,
ініційоване МВС у травні. Понад 1 мільйон 726 тисяч громадян України
взяли участь в опитуванні. Більше половини респондентів - 58,75% -
обрали можливість володіння і носіння пістолетів для особистого захисту,
тоді ж як 22% висловилися проти володіння ними.
Радник міністра внутрішніх справ Вадим Денисенко зазначив DW,
що з початку повномасштабного вторгнення сприйняття цивільної зброї
у суспільстві змінилося. Однак поспішних рішень щодо цього краще не приймати.
До 24 лютого Людмила Держипольська не особливо задумувалася
щодо озброєння себе і родини. Тепер жінка активно підтримує легалізацію зброї.
Людмила зазначає, що обіг зброї у суспільстві збільшиться у зв'язку з війною.
Активістці некомфортно усвідомлювати, що більшість цієї зброї буде нелегальною.
Будь-який контроль - це офіційно. Це легалізація, контроль, облік.
Все, що ми зараз маємо - це без обліку. Тому про обіг зброї у нас буде ще довго питання.
Я дуже за закон, за те, щоб розробили, як нею правильно користуватися.
Бо це легалізація. Будь-яка легалізація - це краще, ніж заборона. Бо ти маєш правила гри.
Людмила очікує відкриття доступу до короткоствольної зброї.
Жінка вважає, що це найкращий інструмент самозахисту.
Вкотре я наполягаю, що короткоствол - це, по-перше, жіноча зброя, жіночий захист.
Тому що гуляти ввечері уже давно перестало бути безпечним для жінок, на жаль.
Тобто самозахист - короткоствол, і обов'язково вміти ним користуватися.
Зброя, як авто, коли ви її поставите собі в гараж - не значить, що ви зараз сіли і поїхали.
Так само зі зброєю - ви маєте нею навчитися користуватися,
ви маєте постійно ходити в тир відстрілювати її, щоб не забувати,
рука не забула, як це робити.
Попри підтримку легалізації зброї і в соціологічних опитуваннях, і в Дії,
деякі експерти все ж побоюються, що в мирний час масове володіння зброєю
призведе до її хаотичного застосування.
Можуть збільшитися випадки використання зброї у побутових конфліктах,
кількість збройних нападів, а також самогубств.
Наразі невідомо, коли у парламенті повернуться до розгляду питання цивільної зброї.
За словами експертів, на це має бути політична воля.
Однак війна створює тиск на чиновників, що унеможливлює затягування
й ігнорування питання обігу зброї. А отже, час прийняти виважене рішення,
кому і за яких умов дозволяти користуватися короткоствольною зброєю.